et rentrent alors maintenant on va on va
revenir en france avec le biographique
de condorcet évidemment question à
laquelle on ne peut pas jouer échapperez
pas c'est comment condorcet s'est il
introduit chez les badinter autrement
dit lequel de vous deux a ramené un soir
condorcet au domicile c'est vous qui
l'avait ramené la tonne par ailleurs il
est inévitable quand on étudie
l'histoire des femmes de rencontrer
condorcet qui est de mon point de vue le
plus beau le plus radical des féministes
et le plus en avance sur son temps alors
à chaque fois que j'ai pu j'ai rendu
hommage à condorcet j'ai fait sa
connaissance comme ça mais dont il était
déjà très sympathique et je dois dire
que quand j'ai perçu son combat
magnifique pour la libération des noirs
là ça a été une vraie séduction vous en
avait parlé à votre mari oui j'en ai pas
mais mon mari mais lui-même commencé à
être très sérieusement intéressé par
condorcet et vous avez donc décidé
conjointement d'écrire la biographie des
condensés oui mais ça faisait très
longtemps que vous voulez écrire un
livre ensemble c'était pas exactement
l'époque quand moi j'étais j'ai commencé
à m'occuper de condorcet mais aussitôt
que robert a pu et il s'est
immédiatement mis dans la documentation
de condorcet avec aussi je crois ce
désir de connaître un des premiers
républicain donc oui oui et ses jeux
je précise qu'ils devaient a dit oui
c'est on était tout à fait décider
écrire un livre
mais le sujet c'est pas si facile à tord
et parce que les travaux d'elisabeth les
champs d'intérêt elisabeth les
conceptions et la bête ce sont les
évidemment ce sont les siennes et moi
mes champs d'intérêt les partageant
souvent tous les deux mais son joignent
pas pleinement donc le problème était
comment trouver où nous retrouver et
condorcet oui y'a mesure que mal à
parler et à mesure que j'avançais
moi-même dans la connaissance de
condorcet savez c'est vraiment alors
profondément l'homme qui combat
l'injustice
10ème et pourquoi est ce qu'on l'a perdu
toutes les justes causes il les a
soutenus et mesure que je découvrais sly
et le combat et pour les protestants et
pour les juger comme je vais te la dit
pour les noirs ne se mesure pas
l'intensité cette bataille-là la lutte
pour les droits de l'homme enfin il a
fait une constitution alors est ce que
le réseau ce qui est frappant c'est que
c'est pas seulement un des grands hommes
de la révolution française
c'est aujourd'hui à travers tous ces
combats un intellectuel du 20e siècle
oui tout à fait alors ça c'est frappant
ça c'est vraiment parce que il n'ya pas
de doute que je pour nous deux en tous
les cas mais peut-être aussi pour les
lecteurs condorcet incarne tous les
grands combats qu'on continue à mener
aujourd'hui et au fond il symbolise la
grande la beauté de la révolution pas
son aspect critiquable je présente aussi
quand même parce que les victimes de
révolutionner ce que dira c'est tous les
combats qu'il a menés et on fonce utile
à apporter à la communauté humaine
ce sont ce qui est positif de la
révolution et surtout les débats que
l'on mène aujourd'hui parce que je ne
peux pas ne pas être frappé par le fait
qu' aujourd'hui en ce moment tous les
hommes politiques de droite ou de gauche
sont en train de dire il faut repenser
l'instruction publique parce qu'on sent
que c'est une urgence
or je crois qu'il ya encore peu de
français qui savent aujourd'hui que
l'homme qui a vraiment pensé
l'instruction publique comme fondement
de la république c'était condorcet et
que jules ferry lui a emprunté
l'essentiel de sa pensée à part ça c'est
une actualité fall au fond vous auriez
voulu pour amis et tous les deux oui
mais on est on a fini le travail qu'on
travaille le problème encore plus ce
qu'on commence et puis sa femme
moi je suis et ça reste dans sa manche
très amoureuse oui mais il ya quand même
quelques nuances dans le portrait que
vous faites là mais l'hôtesse qu'il ya
des nuances dans le jugement que l'un et
l'autre vous porter aussi vraiment ça il
vraiment aucune n'eurent aucune hewlett
vraiment on en a beaucoup parlé et la
faire non on peut avoir des critiques
ont pondu par on n'est pas géographique
au nom peu d'emplois les choses ne vont
pas aller commettre des erreurs de
certains voient là
alors on fleurs alors mais on déplore
ghazi commet des erreurs et on essaye de
trouver et puis quand il accepte d'être
le trésorier du roi et que l'euro a pu
s'abstenir il allait s'abstenir là là
vous dites non il ne condamne pas les
masses art concept en voilà oui et je
dois dire que ça se sente micheline y en
aura et mais non c'est vrai aussi que
parier cet instant là dans ces jours là
berlin est tombé les prussiens
s'approche on sait par le manifeste de
breivik
ce qu'il prépare lorsqu'ils prendront
part et comme ils le pensent et la
tension est extraordinaire et puis vous
payez que la nuit qui précède
robespierre a dénoncé à la commune les
girondins il ya un complot toujours un
complot un complot pour livrer par yeux
de la brasse vic et ses complots ils en
dénoncent les auteurs
nous sommes dans un moment où toutes les
rumeurs pour prendre corps on a fait une
descente je défaut l'an oui nation et
non parce que c'est un moment que j'ai
pas pour les partis c'est vrai que
j'aurais voulu vous condensé se
précipite à la mairie c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient moins bons mais adam madame peu
contre c'est sophie écrit il est
peut-être vue et qu'elle laisse parler
son coeur quand elle écrit elle a mis à
l'angleterre
personne ne l'a fait personne ne l'a
fait faisons connaissance avec condorcet
et pour ce faire je vais vous poser nous
pose des questions je donnais un mot ou
un non jésuite jésuites
écoutez bien vous qui êtes dominicains
c'est bien quand traumatismes graves
dans la vie de condorcet parce que en
amour il y a eu certainement dans le
collège où il était il a eu des amours
je pense avec d'autres jeunes gens et
qui a eu probablement humiliations de la
part des de ses maîtres jésuites qui ont
été pour lui d'une cruauté d'une douleur
si terrible qu'il en a gardé pour
toujours une haine profonde de ses
maîtres
et c'est vrai que ça engendrait chez lui
un anticléricalisme foudroyant et alors
il est athée et anticlérical il est apte
et anticlérical comme ça presque
personnes ont visité les moyens mais oui
mais curieusement tout en étant très
tolérante ont ce qu'ils pratiquent
oui parce qu'ils le disent et ils n'en
veux pas aux églises mais aux prêtres et
et non seulement il est très tolérant et
il dit d'ailleurs une erreur a le même
droit à la vérité de s'exprimer mais en
plus je crois que les il a montré sa
tolérance par son combat à fond pour les
religions protestante pour les
protestants oui alors il publie même de
2,1 fois de plus bien pamphlet vraiment
anticlérical et il envoie le tiercé
l'almanach anti superstitieux qui n'a
pas fait paraître finalement mais qui
doit être absolument chaque jour de
l'année
c'était un calendrier d'un genre spécial
célébrer à massac fait par les prêtres
catholiques partout dans le monde alors
c'est absolument avoir je crois que ça
été cathartique pour les et je crois qu
il a craché comme ça ces espèces de
pardonnez moi mon père mais de rejet
absolu de ces prêtres là en tous les cas
et ça a été à peu près fini sa supposée
des informations assez exceptionnel où
il ya beaucoup d'imagination quand même
pour 365 jours dans le monde entier ce
que je ce que je trouve va de très très
étrange chez davies est justement
qu'elle fut à ce point at et dans ce
siècle des lumières est pratiquement
fille spirituelle de la lambert lambert
qui dit que la raison ne suffit pas et
qu'il faut une révélation
alors que pour lui la raison suffit et
que si on suit la raison le monde va
devenir un monde complètement transformé
ça c'est son originalité gc font du
xviiie c'est ça fait pour ça que c'est
une vieille ça m est pas seulement un
élèment et mon père ça c'est quand même
la faute des jésuites et j'ai toujours
entendu dire que les dominicains quand
on entend dire du mal des jésuites ma
foi au s'opposent fribourg tarhouna et
les rendements de 50 ans c'est plus vrai
maintenant nous allons au nom bien aussi
qu'il est tellement ideally
east ya une telle foi dans le progrès à
moi de moi ce qui me frappe c'est que
vous disiez c'est un intellectuel de
notre époque oui par toutes les causes
qu'il défend oui certainement
il me semble que par 7 cette confiance
profonde dans la nature de l'homme un
moment si sombre où cette esquisse des
progrès de l'esprit humain
il alla commence au fond quelques mois
il me semble avant son emprisonnement et
sa mort dans une période très très
sombres après avoir vu avaient tous leur
verbe de ce qu'ils pouvaient de tout
sans quoi il pouvait croire
je trouve ça à la fois splendide et un
peu effrayant et papa tènement de notre
époque où il semble qu'on est un peu
désabusé sur cette nature humaine et sur
ses progrès de l'esprit mais même quand
on combat pour des voiliers kg + bien
temps gagnant enfin je sais frag
condensé absolue dans l'avenir de
l'humanité
c'est vrai il n'y a pas de raison de
désespérer mais c'est une autre question
mon père je tiens quand même à dire
toujours là pour voler au secours de
confort c'est simplement pour marquer
très précisément que quand il élabore le
projet sur l'école vous avez remarqué
qu' il n'est pas question à cet égard de
supprimer les écoles privées pas du tout
vous avez remarqué que finalement ce
qu'il anime
c'est l'esprit de tolérance qui la
vivent en liberté les cultes est un
mythe défense tout est ouverte et c'est
certain venir chez lui il sait que c'est
très rare parce qu'il ya toujours une
commune les inquiète admirable chez leur
deuxième aux mathématiques faut quand
même qu'on le dise alors mathématiques
c'est vous alors matinée qnx je crois le
bonheur absolu de condorcet il est
naturellement très doué je crois que cet
amour des mathématiques a certainement
été stimulé par sa timidité sa
difficulté de deux contacts y lit mal
dans les salons et qu'il n'est bien que
dans l'abstraction est bon il est doué
et en plus j'ai l'impression que c'est
l'album
et vous aurez peut-être remarqué quand
il a des chagrins d'amour il vient 30 à
la fin il est enfermé comme un rat dans
sedan ça car qu'est-ce qui fait des
mathématiques il en fera toute sa vie
gco moment où ça va mal chez lui ça
suscite ça provoque un mieux cet homme
au lieu comme d'alembert quand il était
dépressif qui ne peut plus rien faire
lui au contraire ça lui redonne la vie
et c'est un mathématicien quand même
très brillant puisque à 26 ans il est
reconnu comme un des cinq six grands en
europe et devient d'ailleurs secrétaire
de l'académie des sciences de la terre
perpétuel avec les thèmes habituels et
il entre à l'académie française beaucoup
plus jeune que vous mombert prendre
maintenant 35 ans a fait rêver quand
même marqué dès la rentrée à 27 ans à
l'académie des cas limités sur ce qui
est encore plus remarquable
effectivement il ya la fin j'ai c'est ce
qui fait également ce dernier c'est vrai
que il y à commencer donc par un dd un
travail très abstrait sur le calcul
intégral qui a été saluée comme une
nouveauté
et moi j'ai été très touché par le fait
qu'au moment où il sent la mort très
proche où il sent que c'est fichu
il fait deux choses juste avant de
partir de ça de son refuge
d'une part il met le point final à ses
recherches sur le calcul intégral et les
confie à la personne dans un sac de
toile et ce dernier geste pour un des
plus grands mathématiciens d'europe qui
donc pour lui l'urgence absolue il écrit
un petit traité d'arithmétique pour que
les instituteurs puissent apprendre
l'arithmétique aux enfants aux enfants
de 5-6 ans toujours sens de la pédagogie
mais qu'au moment où on sent la mort est
prouvée au fond l'envi de parachever sa
vie en étant utile aux petits-enfants et
c'est un petit traité la critique je
trouve ça terriblement touchant oui
c'est splendide est est ce que cette
rigueur de la logique dans les
mathématiques est ce que ils ne
l'appliquent pas dans l'est je dirais
d'allant politique en morale oui
il a une conviction il y a des lois
scientifiques
la raison les découvre cela est vrai
pour tous les faits pour tous les
phénomènes et c'est vrai aussi pour la
société dont il est à la recherche de
l'équation parfaite
par exemple dans le domaine
constitutionnelle alors par deux
principes on les applique
et ça donne d'ailleurs une constitution
extraordinairement développer c'est la
plus longue que je connaisse et dieu
sait que nous sommes un pays producteur
de vin sommateurs de constitution
certainement le plus productif du monde
mais j'ajouterai que ça n'a pas été
seulement un mathématicien abstrait et
des listes c'est qui pose tout de même
les fondements des sciences sociales
c'est-à-dire une espace qu'il appelait
l'arithmétique politique aux
mathématiques social c'est lui qui le
premier s'intéresse en france avec cette
ardeur aux probabilités comment
appliquer les probabilités aux
phénomènes sociaux politiques et il est
d'une certaine façon le père fondateur
des sciences sociales et je dirais le
précurseur de burqa et d'auguste compte
évidemment donc dont il est le père
reconnu elisabeth badinter minutes
prononcé le mot père alors je vais dire
d'alembert turgot et voltaire
qui sont ces trois papas oui mais qui
sont des pères magnifique et vous savez
ce qui m'a vraiment touché c'est que ces
trois paires ont été d'une tendresse
d'affection d'une attention pour lui
quotidienne tout à fait extraordinaire
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a pris chez ses
trois pères d'abord d'alembert saidal
ans berthe il découvre ses d'alembert
qui l'introduit dans le monde et c'est
d'alembert et julie de lespinasse si le
type qui font ses parents d'une certaine
façon alors d'alembert lui a appris avec
beaucoup de rigueur l'amour de la vérité
et il faut dire la méfiance à l'égard
des puissants la méfiance à l'égard de
l'argent de turgot qui lie également
aimait tendrement et dont il a été le
collaborateur
il a hérité le goût de la politique et
du bien public
c'est certain c'est une grosse taille
immense ministre et là il a appris
auprès de ce ministre beaucoup de choses
et alors de voltaire de voltaire il a il
a certainement développer parce que moi
je crois qu'ils l'avaient bien avant de
connaître voltaire ce goût frénétique de
la défense des opprimés et c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu cette rencontre
extraordinaire à ferney
où il va visiter voltaire en compagnie
d' à l'envers pour soigner d'alembert de
sa dépression nerveuse et pendant quinze
jours là il s'est passé à fermer des
choses extraordinaires des accords entre
3 pour ce soutien quoi qu'il arrive et
là je pense que voltaire la marque est
élu à parler de tous ces combats pour
callas pour sylvaine donc dont condorcet
a hérité et sa personne âgée mais quand
on condorcet public des pamphlets
anonymement
quand même volonté est pas très content
parce qu'on l'accuse lee voltaire
d'avoir écrit ses pamphlets tous les
malheurs lui retombe dessus et c'est
vraiment cette voltaire c'est à dire que
condorcet l'expression absolue des
combats de voltaire mais voltaire a
tellement peur c'est pour ça qu'il est à
faire mais à deux pas de la fed de la
suisse que il n'en veut à condorcet
parce qu'il a peur qu'on dise et
voltaire qu'il a fait mais bon il ya ces
petites poires 10 de voltaire mais ça
n'empêche pas une affection formidable
quelquefois il pousse même voltaire pour
le moment la condamnation du chevalier
de la barre
celui-ci vous attendez votre rôle à vous
votre rôle à bout du bayern lui a légué
le combat pour la réhabilitation de la
barre ce sens que pour l'or s'est amené
avec une modestie inouïe c'est une des
grandes caractéristiques de mon d'orsay
c'est qu'il est la vanité c'est de fait
personne ne sait que c'est lui qui s'est
occupé de cette affaire
alors il a la maladie du pamphlet des
quelque chose ne va pas et hop ifip ont
un pamphlet et le publie généralement
anonymement mais on aura publié des
dizaines et des dizaines de pamphlets
oui ces oeuvres complètes sont financées
c'est là en effet les manuscrits de la
bibliothèque de l'institut l'infini
méridien final les crises aussi de
l'époque on l'a écrit beaucoup de
pamphlets et alors je crois que ça c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle le grand
mathématicien hacker condorcet à une
image un peu flou parce que cet homme
qui devrait être objectif rigoureux à
différents atouts est activement à
sillonner et prince afflux effectivement
prête souvent très dures chez les
badinter ce nom comme ça c'est toujours
elizabeth qui parlent plus que robert
avait coûté robert écouter admire les
jeunes semblent toujours si grave j'ai
encore plus quand elle parle de
condorcet
alors quand je vous pose une question
maintenant c'est les femmes alors c'est
bon alors toujours bon alors c'est bon
alors condorcet et les femmes
quand même jusqu'à l'âge de 40 ans c'est
quand même un grand nigaud notre
condorcet s'écraserait grandglise
absolument le mot dénigrons non c'est un
homme qui a certainement de profonds
problèmes partie la relation avec les
femmes se joue toujours sur le mode fils
père ou tout au plus frères soeurs et
c'est pas un niveau c'est un homme qui
je vous le rappelle a été certainement
très traumatisés dans son adolescence
avec des problèmes n'oubliez pas non
plus qu'il a été élevé par sa mère à
duisans si oui jusqu'à la jda puisqu'à
l'âge de neuf ans jusqu'à l'âge de deux
ans mais c'est pas facile après d'être
un séducteur un homme à la maison pas de
sa faute mais je dis quand même selon
les goûts il a des circonstances
atténuantes
il a tout de même risqué l'enlèvement
d'une jeune fille il a risqué la ville a
rappelé maintenant il l'a enlevé on a
retrouvé la jeune fille a blast il ya
cette correspondance publiée en même
temps avec eux avec madame suhard un
personnage étonnant c'est madame sueur
et ils ont le même âge ont même un joli
long elle est six mois plus vieille que
lui et entre ya rien du tout non il ya
eu une amitié je moi je pensais un peu
amoureuse 8 d'amour comme c'est une
petite bourgeoise qui tient sa
réputation et que je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle ait à grand tempérament elle n'a
pas cherché tellement avoir plus de
condorcet mais c'est un peu ambigu
en tous les cas pendant les quatre
premières années de leur correspondance
et alors elle fout elle vit les échecs
amoureux et les passions amoureuses de
condorcet par intermédiaire et elle se
réjouit de son rôle de conseillère
pygmalion pygmalion et vous remarquez
que c'est un très mauvais élève à lui
donne des tapes mais ça c'est une toute
petite partie de la correspondance est
le diable de ses premiers 200 lettres
quelques-unes d'ailleurs au mari
monsieur super oui si il écrit
d'ailleurs on voit qu'il écrit
magnifiquement mai mais c'est qu'il est
quand même terrifiant c'est de
correspondance est qu il ya une
confiance en eux extraordinaire au début
tant qu'il n'y a pas la révolution
et puis à la fin eh bien ils sont de
l'eau chacun d'un côté de la barrière
ils sont déjà un peu séparés à cause de
mesquer c'est à dire que condorcet et le
collaborateur chéri de turgot et necker
et le l'ennemi de turbo alors comme
madame soir reçoit une petite pension de
necker elle descend des cas contre
morsay et là on sent que les gens
premiers froids mais c'est vrai et c'est
ça le grand problème
la vraie coupure la vraie cassure c'est
une cassure politique comme ça peut
exister d'ailleurs en d'autres temps
elle restera avec son mari un couple je
pense de monarchie constitutionnelle
sont des gens molero et lui devient un
véritable républicain et là ça sera la
rue devant et notre condorcet vers l'âge
de quarante et quelques années se marie
il se marie avec sophie dont robert
badinter est fou amoureux et il ya de
quoi parce que c'est vrai qu'il est
attendu mais quand même il a fait un
très beau mariage et ça fait un couple
assez étonnant étonnant détonnant et une
remarque me dit c'est anigo mais il a
quand même pu séduire la plus jolie
femme de libéraux est la plus
intelligente et et manifestement il ya
un charme inouï puisque tous les zénith
pour leur secte vieux scène ont attaqué
et l'ont attaqué aussi à travers sa
femme tous tous elle est quand même
merveilleux c'est dommage qu'on n'ait
pas ici le portrait de sophie à
l'éthique ce qui est visuel et lettres
quel talent et quel manque d'allant
ouais enfin c'est un coup vous vous
retrouvez un peu dans ce couple ou non
non vous nous ferez pas dire ça non pas
du tout non non je trouverais ville ceci
un sens de ce qui était opportun qui
m'impressionne lorsqu'il est en grande
dépression ou un moment où il est caché
chez madame vernet rue servandoni
maintenant je ne sais pas comment ça
s'appelait pas face à fait la rue des
fossés ou maintenance est resté avant
daniel conservant notre la maison existe
toujours
oui alors il est la tâche et et il
commence à faire un nom on sent la
dépression nerveuse alors c'est elle qui
ou alors qu'il écrit des lettres à la
convention
tu ne pas avoir aucun effet c'est elle
qui lui dit de se remettre à sa
recherche des progrès d'esprit blanc en
vue le bonheur de l'humanité
alors du coup ils abandonnent les
pamphlets qui l'envoyaient et il se met
il retrouve une certaine vitalité
intellectuelle et morale
elle a compris qu'on prenne il a compris
que il est là et il a évidemment toutes
les angoisses celui ci s'interroge ses
amis face ou vont passer
quine le pays est envahi la république
menacée il est comme tous les hommes
politiques de cette session il
s'interroge sûrement il se dit est-ce
que j'ai bien fait il essaye de
justifier qu'elle comprend qu'il se perd
en revivant ça il est d'une certaine
manière et le vivre en est à la fois son
souffle et sa liberté d'être à québec
parce qu'elle lui dit écrit et à ce
moment là il fait cette oeuvre
évidemment il faut dire le lit pour
connaître tout le parcours de condorcet
pendant la révolution
de même une chose qui le parce qu'on n'a
pas le temps de tout raconter bien
entendu c'est que ses rapports avec
louis saez c'est que donc il va voter la
défiance 2016
mais il va tout à fait curieux c'est
qu'il n'a pas voté la mort 7 c'est
vraiment décisif ayant moins et pour moi
c'était l'instant la presse que le piège
convenait je pensais perdre carrés
comprendra je pensais au diable qui
regarde ça là comme la gargouille notre
dame
là il est d'une certaine manière
coincé et c'est l'éthique de
responsabilité et l'éthique de
conviction
bon c'est un abolitionniste il a
toujours mené le combat pour l'abolition
et puis le moment est venu mais c'est à
cet instant un homme politique important
et après tout ce que disent ça juste
robespierre il faut la coupure est
réversible il faut que le roi meurt pour
que la république soit fondée il ne faut
pas le laisser ainsi la
contre-révolution et se ralliera
toujours de lui mais il ya des raisons
politiques très fortes et après tout ce
discours là condorcet convaincu depuis
très longtemps que lui c'est ce travail
que l'on trahit la beauté layher
coupable mais à ce moment là vous l'avez
vu il n'hésite pas et dit
ne peut pas jeter la mort parce que je
suis contre la peine de mort ce qui vous
sert de manière va le perdre
cela contribuera certes vous savez je
viens se représenter cette nuit là moi
j'ai regardé j'ai été jusqu'au procès
verbaux parce que je voulais on a
commencé à voter à six heures et demie
du soir
on finira le lendemain à environ six
heures du soir
les tribunes sont pleines la nuit
s'avance et je me dis à quel moment at
il voté car on écoute les autres voté il
ya les explications de vote et les
tribunes réagissent et je pensais qu'ils
avaient voté à l'heure creuse et pas du
tout je me suis rendu compte en comptant
le nombre de pages et en lisant à haute
voix ce à quel moment ils avaient pu
voter ce devait être car le la fin de la
matinée
par conséquent plus on s'approche de la
décision plus la tension devient grand
et des hommes aussi courageuse vergnaud
beaucoup de caractère au dernier moment
une pression les genres bon encontre
l'atmosphère des tribunes la mort n'a
pas qu'on leur sert pas il germa vous
connaissiez condorcet aussi bien le non
absolument pas au gia je connaissais le
condorcet de l'enseignement dans une
instruction publique et puis le
condorcet convaincu que l'ignorance et
la première chose à combattre oui pas de
liberté il n'y a pas de la folie c'est
ça et peut-être que la richesse ils
évoquent dans la raison la suprématie de
la raison c'est plutôt dans l' inverse
de l'ignorance plus il ya une raison et
moi zyed ignorance plus il ya de chances
d'aller peut-être calvet ya lieu il ya
autre chose
un bon moyen de préjugés c'est très
important ce triomphe de la raison celle
ci on compte nuances et ça et c'est
aussi cette conviction que la république
c'est à dire la liberté et l'égalité la
liberté quand il n'ya pas de savoir
quand il n'y a pas de connaissance ce
n'est pas possible pour quiconque
il ya ceux qui savent et permet à ceux
qui croient dit il pense évidemment à la
superstition
il n'y a pas de liberté possible s'il
n'y est pas d'abord la liberté de
l'esprit encore moins d'égalité possible
s'il n'y a pas accès à la structure
et c'est là c'est vrai c'est c'est le
message si profond et c'est vrai si
actuel de condorcet
public plus beau sens du terme c'est
d'abord l'instruction de tous vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé je veux dire la ss
de cruauté de l'histoire son grand
rapport sur l'instruction publique
il le fait il rédige il le fait à
prouver on prend date
c'est 21 avril ce jour là ce jour là le
roi décide d'aller à l'assemblée
législative pour demander à ce qu'on
vote
la déclaration de guerre et les tribunes
sont pleines et tout le monde est là ils
n'ont pas débuté et depuis le matin on
assiège l'assemblée législative pour
montrer que il faut respecter l'ordre du
jour
on commence par le rapport sur
l'instruction publique 20 minutes
personne n'écoute
et le livre you ça tombe à plat arrive
le roi et c'est fini pratiquement on ne
parlera plus jamais le rapport sur ce
qu'ils ont fait mais ça c'est quand on y
pense
tarifs pour lui bon je laisse au lecteur
le soin de découvrir ces rapports
avaient vraiment avec robespierre
oui mais ça sera pris sur votre temps
répète on est vrai que vous avez
l'éternité m'amène spontanée je le mets
le condorcet je reconnais son
originalité qui est très grande mais
j'ai été un peu étonné de ne pas voir ça
me rappelle les situations antérieures
des forces intérieures
par exemple je croyais pas je vais
vouloir récupérer ou d'orsay et en faire
un fils de saint thomas d'aquin
mais quand même déjà saint thomas
d'aquin avait désacraliser le bois
naturel donné à la raison son autonomie
vous allez j'ai ensuite chez les
protestants l'école du droit naturel ou
le xviie et xviiie siècles nous allions
en espagne les théologiens comme vitoria
qui ont écrit sur la libération des
flammes ou qu'ils ont les plus très
dramatiquement comme la ciaf si vous
voulez je dors ensuite on revoit
tonnacquois arrivée condorcet mais il
reprenait ou font un héritage qui
s'était quelque peu diluées dans les
deux ou trois siècles précédents
oui alors réponse de robert badinter
c'est vrai mais je vais tenir le fond le
font pour nous c'est que dans cette
époque et pour cet homme là regardez
combien se sont tenues droit on regarde
leurs principes
lui il n'a pas les mains pleines de sang
aucune corruption et aucune
compromission il est mort le dire comme
il le devait avec ses convictions et le
message qu'il avait eu la livrer cent
ans plus tard il écrirait la république
quand on s'est beaucoup interrogé sur ce
que doit être le comportement d'un
intellectuel en politique suivre
condorcet au jour le jour
c'est un c'est un vrai réconfort
je peux le site et amazon c'est un vrai
réconfort donc je tenais à revenir
quant à la question mais alors laissons
là parce que oui parce que là vous êtes
victime
je vous repère de condorcet la ville de
grandes oreilles en avant je
reconnaîtrais là encore son
anticléricalisme sortante a eu tous
admirent alors il va me font diamant
alors voilà votre jour